[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un nom arrêter ça non non non
je ne peux rien faire je ne peux rien
faire je ne peux rien faire arrêter
je ne peux pas vous aider à arrêter
[Musique]
recherche
3 fait recette
improbable à khobar
fiche le camp tu n'as pas réussi à nous
sauver tu n'a rien à faire ici fiche le
grand monsieur que têtu pourquoi l'a
perdu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
venez voir mon rendez moi mon fils en
télé bois tout le monde mais plus
personne
[Musique]
commandant commandant nous avons des
vibrations anormales au niveau des
propulseurs on ne peut plus les pousser
au dessus de 60 % puissance maximale
puissance maximale e commandant
d'abandonner pas aussi facilement
l'ennemi ne nous attendra pas
commandant vous devez donner l'ordre
d'interrompre l'exercice sinon le
vaisseau ne tiendra pas n'abandonnez pas
aussi facilement
vous le savez bien l'ennemi n'attendra
pas commandant je vous en prie sur les
cas l'exercice
nous ne pouvons perdre à la fois le
vaisseau et l'équipage ouais c'est vrai
ce n'est qu'un simple exercice nous
arrêtons à racler l'exercice ingénieur
chef occupez vous des réparations bas
classeur prenez les commandes ne
m'appelez quand tu as besoin d'avant il
n'était pas vraiment comme est ce à dire
qu'il était commandant en chef de la
flotte pendant la grande guerre
remarquez il ya de quoi devenir fou a
commandé un vieux rafiot comme celui-ci
je t'interdis formellement de le juger
je suis sûr qu'il se reprendra
alors ça y est vous avez donné votre
démission oui c'est exact
et d'ailleurs le vaisseau est déjà
attribué à quelqu'un écoutez je sais que
la guerre contre les humanoïdes est
terminée depuis quelques temps mais êtes
vous certain que nous sommes réellement
en paix qu'il n'y a plus rien à craindre
je n'ai pas pu je n'ai pas pu protéger
qui que ce soit même ma famille je les
laisser périr vous savez parfaitement
que tout ce qui est arrivé n'est pas
uniquement de votre faute
et combien de fois devrais-je ou encore
vous répéter que la terre a toujours
besoin de peau c'est trop tard j'ai déjà
pris ma décision ne vous sauvez pas
rester là enlevez votre casquette est
posée l'inter comme ça on est à égalité
il n'y a plus de grade
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça suffit arrête de fuir 0 crois-tu être
le seul le seul à avoir perdu toute ta
famille c'est justement maintenant notre
avenir se joue que tu déclares en fait
notre planète n'est pas encore morte
il reste des êtres humains à protéger tu
ne peux pas abandonner
tu dois continuer cette mission je sais
que c'est difficile mais prend sur toi
je considère que tu dois au moins cela
la mémoire de tous ceux qui ont disparu
pendant la grande guerre
c'est vrai je sais je suis désolé
non non mon pauvre garçon pourquoi
pourquoi te sens-tu coupable à ce point
[Rires]
[Musique]
message à l'intention du corps voire
stopper les machines
si vous n'obéissez pas souvent le feu
avait son non identifiés en approche à
cinq mille équipages branle bas de
combat armé les canes ont armé les
canons sont bien emparés attiré top et
les machines obéissait aux ordres nous
ouvrant le feu ce feu nous avons reçu un
sos commandant pouvez-vous regagner la
passerelle immédiatement attaques des
pirates de l'espace dans l'orbité de
jupiter
[Musique]
je ne peux rien faire non pas été ça je
ne peux rien faire
il faut savoir 800
[Musique]
chef navigateur aux rapports déterminer
la position de l'ennemi
à vos ordres position déterminée
contacté le niveau terrestre et
transmettez un message nous nous rendons
dans la zone de combat leur porter
secours à tout l'équipage du cag héros
prend le bas de combat équipage prêts
pour la bataille
en avant toute
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce que ça donne y'a du nous
venons c'est comme d'habitude toujours
comme d'habitude rien tarbes commandant
on s'ennuie un peu qu'est ce qu'on fait
détruisez ce vaisseau à l'intention du
vaisseau non identifié ici ou à 12,0
commandant du cag héros appartenant à la
flotte de ligne terrestre
rendez-vous tous nos canaux sont pointés
sur vous
comment d'un message du vaisseau ennemi
il nous ordonne de nous rendent alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait on ignore leur
ordre ce n'est qu'une vulgaire
patrouille à mougins
ça y est je lai bariatrique ap comment
dans les mines ou tire dessus
esquivez à ses frontaliers mais paie pas
à tout l'équipage préparez-vous à
l'impact
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand nous a manqué exact et il l'a fait
volontairement
mais dans ce cas ça signifie une seule
chose c'est qu'ils nous tirent dessus en
manuel j'avoue que je suis surpris
j'ignore qui ils sont mais ils sont
vraiment très forts que faisons-nous
maintenant commandant oui ils sont
vraiment forts analyse des messages
envoyés aux galères terminé vaisseau et
demie 0013 des sceaux appartenant au
gouvernement galactique du système
solaire extérieur numéro
d'immatriculation 2 4 5 3 6 mai sont en
route de pau c'est un des vaisseaux des
humanoïdes je crois que nous n'avons
aucune chance nous devrions laisser
tomber commandant l'ennemi est sûre
notre fréquence envoi d'un nouveau
message message ou gameiro
désarmé immédiatement vos canons et
quitter ce secteur
nous ne voulons aucun mal aux terriens
message aux vaisseaux non identifiés
l'unio terrestres et les humanoïdes ont
conclu un traité de paix jusqu'ici il a
été scrupuleusement respectée nous
considérons de ce fait que toute attaque
sera une violation très grave du pacte
de non-agression ordre de désarmer et de
vous rendre immédiatement où nous
passons à l'attack commandant vous
n'êtes pas sérieux
si au contraire très sérieux nous
appartenons à la force de l'union
terrestre et nous devons faire notre
devoir sauver résonne comme honda et ce
sont eux qui ont attaqué sa ses sous
s'ils veulent la bataille croyez moi ils
vont l'avoir
comment dans son peignoir à 3 sur
l'objectif en avant officier mécanicien
mettez les gaz pleine puissance
il reprend du poil de la bête il veut
vraiment des trucs ce vaisseau nous
n'avons pas d'autres vaisseaux
disponibles faites attention à celui ci
nous n'avons pas d'autres vaisseaux
disponible et je sais qu'on peut taire
backelite heures rails je te charge de
détruire leurs canaux principal
vous pouvez compter sur moi comme en
dame
[Musique]
c'est un modèle ans vient pas ou oraux
commandant le vaisseau ennemi a l'air de
poser droiture nous intéressant voilà
qui me lance un défi je vais me relever
bien sûr je suis au centre c'est parti
comme un gars
vaisseaux ennemis fonce droit sur nous
on risque la collision calmez vous le
premier qui dévie de sa route a perdu
j'en viens pas qu'ils sont drôlement
courage c'est à tribord
c'est à bâbord
[Musique]
7 les remplisseurs vivre dangereusement
nous perdons de la puissance allez mon
grand quelques ou encore un moment
bonsoir esquivée par tribord part à
tribord tout moi je vois barre à tribord
toutes parts à tribord toutes conservées
par atrium esquivée par tribord barre à
tribord foot
[Musique]
c'est un bilan des dégâts en vitesse
attention il revient à l'attack rail est
ce que tu es prêt c'est ok gestion
opérationnelle komanda message du
vaisseau ennemi gameiro tous nos canons
sont braqués sur vous vous n'avez aucune
chance de vous échapper
mais vous avez bien combattu alors nous
vous laissons la vie sauve pour qui il
se prend
il va détruire tous les vaisseaux de
transport est ce que tu peux l'atteindre
hélas nomme commandant massoud et en
envoyer un message aux vaisseaux ennemis
message aux vaisseaux non identifié
arrêtez tout de suite ne fait pas ça
[Musique]
comment at il osé comment at il pu
commettre un acte aussi barbare ou
nabarra mettait en route tous les
moteurs auxiliaires
c'est impossible tout les propulseurs
sont hors service comment dans le
vaisseau ennemi s'éloigne
malédiction il a réussi à fuir
[Musique]
commandant vous devez savoir que des
vaisseaux du gouvernement galactiques
sont régulièrement attaqués par des
pirates de l'espace
quel que soit l'endroit où ils se
trouvent et que ceci doit cesser oui
madame
je suis au courant parmi ceux qui nous
ont infligé le plus de dommages il en
est un commandé par un humain qui se
nomme albator oui albator c'est aussi
lui qui commandait le vaisseau qui vous
a attaqué son appareil s'appelle l'ombre
de la mort oui c'est ça c'est bien ça
l'ombre de la mort le gouvernement
galactique et décidé que ce sera à nous
mais que reviendra la tâche d'éliminer
ces pirates d'accord et si jamais nous
échoit les humanoïdes et risquent de
rompre le traité de paix si durement
obtenus et à ce moment-là peut-être de
nous déclarer une nouvelle guerre
laissez moi m'occuper de cette affaire
madame et si vous acceptez de me confier
cette mission
j'aimerais que vous m'accordez une
faveur oui quelle est elle je veux que
l'on m'autorise à y aller avec le karyu
vous voulez le karyu oui bien je ferai
part de votre demande au gouverneur
général encore autre chose oui qu'est ce
que c'est le pilotage du caribou est
extrêmement délicat c'est pourquoi si
j'obtiens ce vaisseau j'aurais également
besoin de mon ancien équipage je
m'occuperai de ça aussi
y at il autre chose non ce sera tout
madame très bien alors je compte sur
vous vous le pouvez madame et surtout
tâcher d'être prudent c'est ce que vous
désiriez vous êtes satisfait oui c'est
parfait
il a accepté notre offre mais comment un
homme normal peut-il se porter
volontaire pour une telle mission 6-0
vous dérange à ce point là si vous
voulez le mettre à l'écart il suffira de
trouver un prétexte pour le faire
renvoyer du vaisseau ou même directement
de l'armée et risquer de me retrouver
avec un autre fou furieux comme albator
dans la galaxie
vous ne voudriez pas voir ça j'en suis
certain n'oubliez pas que notre traité
de paix est extrêmement fragile et
facile à rompre à tout moment
[Rires]
[Musique]
je ne reviens pas c'est bien le karyu
bonjour que mon nom je vous attendais je
suis yamaguchi ingénieur en chef au
quartier général des forces terrestres
pour vous servir propos je suis là pour
prendre possession du vaisseau bienvenue
j'étais impatient de vous voir j'ai
beaucoup entendu parler de vous à
allumer toutes les lumières s'il vous
plaît
il est magnifique il avait pourtant été
salement endommagé pendant la guerre oui
mais tous les membres de l'équipe de
maintenance qui ont survécu à la grande
guerre se sont réunis et ont mis tout
leur savoir faire et tout leur coeur
pour réparer ce vaisseau nous avons
également actualisé l'armement
vous allez voir il est parfait merci
infiniment
alors vous êtes contents d'être là on à
barra si c'est lui qui s'est chargé des
réparations vous n'avez pas le moindre
souci à vous faire c'est le meilleur
merci nous avons une autre surprise
commandant l'étendard de la flotte
indépendante
celui sur lequel j'ai prêté serment de
me battre pour la cause tient pour
quelles raisons notre bon commandant en
second bat leiser est il ici on vous a
attribué à nouveau commandant en second
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça vous
allez voir
[Musique]
je suis votre nouveau second mari naoki
aux rapports commandant
[Musique]
oui commandant qu'est ce qu'il y a et
bien rien du tout j'aimerais savoir qui
est allé demander qu'on m'attribue une
nouvelle recrue et bien en fait c'est
moi
vous comprenez j'en avais assez d'avoir
un robot comme commandant second alors
j'ai eu cette idée mais je ne
m'attendais pas à ça commandant je crois
qu'on devrait y aller le vaisseau est
prêt à parier mais eh bien tout
l'équipage sur la passerelle magnifique
ravissante magnifique ravissante été
jeté mon épouse et moi tous vous allez
avoir l'immense plaisir de voyager dans
ce prestigieux vaisseau certains d'entre
vous le connaissent déjà
d'autres vont le découvrir et j'espère
qu'ils apprécieront avec lui nous allons
partir à la chasse aux pirates vérifier
les systèmes électriques celle ci cela
ne m'avait rien
nous sommes prêts pour le départ hisser
l'étendard de la flotte indépendante
à tout l'équipage nous allons
appareiller
équipes de maintenance évacuer la zone
évacuée la zone propulseur anti
gravitationnelle vitesse 12012 enclenché
ouverture des portes
[Musique]
verrouillage du pâtis effectuer des
mouillages du pâtis effectués
[Musique]
c'est bon tout est au vert chez renault
si tout est au vert
tout est ouvert
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui regardez bien ce magnifique appareil
c'est le peso de l'espoir le peso des
derniers hommes de la terre le v12 vos
casquettes bora
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
équipage veillée saluer l'équipe de
maintenance
j'arrive albator je vais te trouver
nous avons un compte à régler
[Musique]
mais hélas à bord du karyu les relations
entre humains et humanoïdes se détériore
au fil des jours
au cours d'un épisode violent marina est
blessé la plus grande confusion règne
dans le vaisseau
[Musique]
temps
c
[Musique]
côté
pour penser ça
jours
[Musique]
les sens
tous
et
moi
[Musique]
sans elle
mon temps
je
[Musique]
des chats
ottawa
[Musique]
toi
oh